عده
ورسوله اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا
محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين اما
بعد
فكلامنا
موصول
حول اوائل سوره
الرعد من كتاب
الله
are where we left yesterday which is
open سوره
الر
قران
that
يقول الله تعالى المف لام ميم را وقد سبق
الكلام على هذه الاحرف تلك ايات الكتاب اي
هذه
ايات من الكتاب فال
الاضافه بمعنى التبعيض والذي انزل اليك من
ربك الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون فهذا ليس عيب في ما انزل على النبي
صلى الله عليه
وسلم وانما العيب في
الناس فالذي
يتلقى هذا
المنزل العيب فيهم الناس اكثرهم لا
يؤمنون وليس هذا عيبا في الحق وانما هو
عيب في الناس لان
الناس
اكثرهم
يدفعهم الهوى يدفعهم
العاطفه
لذلك لا يؤمنون
بالحق
فليس كثره
الاتباع دليلا
لوحده
على صحه الشيء وليس قله الاتباع دليلا
لوحده على فساد او بطلان الشيء هذا امر
مهم وليس معناه كذلك في
المقابل ان كثره الاتباع دليل على
بطلانه ايضا لانه هذا ايضا يخطر على بال
بعض
الناس يصبح يظن ان كل شيء اذا كثر اتباع
او
اذا كثر معتقد
معتقد فانه لا يمكن ان يكون صحيحا لان
الصحيح والحق لابد ان يكون اقليه دائما
هذا خطا غير
صحيح كثره الاتباع وقله الاتباع كثره
المصدقين قله المصدقين ليس دليلا يستقل
بصحه او ابطال
الشيء بشكل عام
لكن تكون
قرينه تكون
قرينه والله عز وجل
يقول وان تطع اكثر من في الارض يضلوك عن
سبيل الله ويقول سبحانه
وتعالى وما اكثر الناس ولو حرصت
بمؤمنين فيقول تعالى والي ينزل اليك من
ربك الحق ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون الله الذي رفع السماوات بغير عمد
ترونها ثم استوى على العرش وسخر الشمس
والقمر كل يجري لاجل مسمى يدبر الامر يفصل
الايات لعلكم بلقاء ربكم
توقنون
الله سبحانه وتالى
الر م
را
arees legation
الله بك
قران
could
الله revelation which be guidance and
legislative will that he has designated
as guidance for man from the time عليه
السلام محمد صل الله عليه وس
الله سبحانه
وتعالى واذا اتينا موسى الكتاب الكتاب مش
القران لقد ارسلنا رسلنا
بالبينات وانزلنا
مع any
الله الله سبحانه
وتعالى ادم عليه السلام اسكن انت وزوجك
الجنه said adam when that wasla will for
adam that was of the b
بك
قران
بك الله سبحانه
وتعال لو نظرنا في كلمه كتاب الكتاب كما
سبق
بيانه وذلك انمه
الكتاب تطلق بها القران وتطلق في القران
ويراد بها الشريعه شريعه الله سبحانه
وتعالى بشكل
عام لان الله سبحانه
وتعالى يطلق كلمه الكتاب
ويريد بها التوراه او الانجيل او الزبور
في القران يقول سبحانه وتعالى واذ اتينا
موسى الكتاب والفرقان لعلكم تهتدون
فلام
هنا الكتاب اللام هذه للعهد للعهد
الذهني يعني
للكتاب
بما يعني هذا الكتاب هو
ما يخطر في الذهن
السامع من انه كتاب الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول تعالى كتاب الله عليكم كتاب الله
عليكم يعني هذا شيء كتبه الله عليكم
وشرعه
فقوله تلك ايات الكتاب اما ان يراد
بالاضافه هذه
التبعيض يعني
تلك من ايات
الكتاب او تلك ايات من الكتاب هذا قد
يراد وقد يكون المراد هذه الايات التي
ينزلها الله سبحانه وتعالى في
القران فانها مجمل جميع الكتب التي انزلها
الله على
انبياءه تلك ايات الكتاب يعني هذه الايات
التي هي ايات القران فيها
جميع ما انزله الله وفيها زبده ما انزله
الله سبحانه وتعالى على عباده من لدن ادم
الى ان تقوم الساعه الى محمد صلى الله
عليه وسلم فهذا الكتاب القران هو
مجمل جميع شرائع الله مجمل جميع كتب الله
وهو اعظم هذه الكتب ولذلك فان هذه الامه
اخر الامم ولكنها اولها يوم القيامه دخولا
في الجنه اولها
حسابا وكذلك هذه الامه شاهده بكتاب الله
على جميع الامم السالفه
السابقه
لماذا لان هذه الامه اتاه اتاها الله
القران اتاها الله
القران وهو اعظم شاهد سبحانه وتعالى كفى
بالله
شهيدا جل
جلاله فهو يقول تلك ايات الكتاب هذه ايات
الكتاب كتاب الله والذي انزل اليك من ربك
يعني وايضا جميع ما انزل اليك من ربك
كله من
الرؤى المتحقق
قبل النبوه عائشه رضي الله عنها ذكرت ان
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم مكت سته
اشهر لا يرى الرؤيا الا وتقع كفلق
النهار وان هذا
الامر استمر معه سته اشهر حتى جاءه الحق
بغار
حراء
كذلك نزول جبريل عليه السلام كذلك ما حصل
له من ايات من تسليم الحجر له وحنين الجدع
و تسبيح الطعام الى غير ذلك من الايات
البينات التي وتيها النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم
وكل هذه الاشياء وايضا السنه فهم
القران لان السنه عباره عن فهم
القران ف والذي انزل اليك من ربك الحق
ولكن اكثر الناس لا
يؤمنون الله سبحانه
وتعالى
ب
الله
‏to and come to down to from your lord
it is the
tru it is
tru most people do not
believe it's not just qur which was
revealed to the prophet عليه ولم there
other things that occurred other angels
that had spoken to visions that he
sleep he was
[Silence]
‏these things are the tru there no in
these
things the is is not the
verity
‏h of people most people do
not why do they not believe they do not
believe because most people are governed
and propelled by emotion most people are
propelled by
desire most
people are not govern by logic they are
not govern by the truth
‏sincerity most people now this doesn't
mean that most people can never get it
right do me
that we are understand from veres of the
قران
that
most that the majority is not
necessarily always
right we're not to also understand that
the majority is always wrong that's
incorrect as well
‏likewise the minority is not always
correct and the minority is not always
incorrect something is not proven
correct incorrect or untrue simply based
on the amount of followers it
has
‏because we assume as human
beings that other human beings don't
believe don't do something until they
thought it through and that is just not
the case most people are not driven by
thought andic most people are
driven الله سبحانه وتالى يقول الله الذي
رفع السماوات بغير
عمد
ترونها يصف نفسه سبحانه
وتعالى بهذه الافعال
العظيمه التي لا
تنسب الى غيره حتى عند
المشركين المشركون
الذين ارسل اليهم النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم يؤمنون بان الله تعالى هو
الخالق
و هو المتفرد بالخلق
والرزق
والتدبير ويؤمنون
باكثر اجزاء او اكثر مسائل توحيد الربوبيه
يعني افعال الله سبحانه
وتعالى وانما يعبدون
غيره تقربا اليه يزعمون ان هذه
الاصنام هي عباره عن
ا صالحين كانوا في السابق مقربين الى الله
سبحانه وتعالى فاذا ما عبدوا هؤلاء
الصالحين فانهم
يقربونه من
الله ما نعبدهم الا ليقربونا الى الله
زلفا هكذا يقول الله سبحانه وتعالى تعبيرا
عن
عقيدتهم فالعرب لا يشكون في
هذا العرب بمعنى العرب الذين ارسل اليهم
وفيهم النبي محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم لابد حتى نفهم عقيده الاسلام وما جاء
به النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم من الا
اعتقاد لا بد ان نفهم المقابل الذين ارسل
فيهم النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ماذا كانوا
يعتقدون هذا امر مهم واعتنى به العلماء
قديما وحديثا اعتنى بهذه العقائد الطبري
رحمه الله في تفسيره وتاريخه وكذلك ابن
كثير
و جم وكثره كاثره من العلماء اهتموا بهذه
العقائد التي كانت
منتشره في اوساط المجتمعات
العربيه في زمن النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
وقبل مبعثه لماذا لان ما جاء في
القران كان مناسبا
لهذا ما جاء في الوحي في القران والسنه
كان
ناطقا و كان ردا على هذه
العقائد كان جوابا على هذه
العقائد فلا بد ان فلا بد ان نفهم ما الذي
كان عليه
العرب عباد الاصنام ما الذي كانوا عليه من
العقيده ومن الايمان ومن التصديق والتكذيب
حينما ارسل فيهم النبي صلى الله عيه عليه
وسلم هم كانوا يعتقدون ان الله الذي رفع
السماوات قوله بغير عمد
ترونها بغير عمد
ترونها هل هذا يعني ان السماوات ليس لها
عمد
والعمد جمع
عماد والعماد هو الاسطوانه يعني
اللي بيحكوا فيها الركن فالله عز وجل رفع
السما رفع السماوات بغير
عمد ترونها يعني هل في عمد لكن لا نراها
ام ليس للسماوات عمد ولذلك لا
نراها خلاف بين
العلماء
والظاهر ان
هذه
الاعمده وهذه العمد فاننا لا
نراها لعدم وجوه لعدم وجودها فالله سبحانه
وتعالى رفع
السماوات وليس لها
اعمده لو كان لها
اعمده لوجدنا الاشاره اليها في ايات اخرى
في القران الله عز وجل ذكر للسماء
والسماوات
ابواب ذكر للسماوات
ا ظاهر وباطن وذكر للسماوات
لكن الاعمده
والعمد فلم
يجئ الاشاره اليها الا في هذه الايه
ومثلها فقوله الله الذي رفع السماوات بغير
عمد ترونها ترونها اي ترون الاعمده او
ترون السماوات نرى السماوات وليس لها
اعمده سبحانه ثم استوى على
العرش قوله
ثم هذا يدل على ان ما جاء بعد يعني حرف ثم
ثم
تدل حرف عطف عطف تدل على عطف ما بعد بعدها
على ما قبلها بالترتيب
الزمني يعني ان ما
قبلها ثم جاء ما بعد ثم م تاخر في الزمن
فقوله ثم استوى على
العرش فهذا فعل من افعال الله سبحانه
وتعالى انه استوى على
عرشه استوى على عرشه استواء يليق بجلاله
سب سبحانه وهو فوق
خلقه لا نقول كيف هو فوق خلقه
ولا نعطل هذا المعنى نعطيه معنى اخر نقول
لا الاستواء هنا ليس على الحقيقه بل
الاستواء المقصود به انه تولى الملك او
العرش كنايه عن الملك والسلطان هذا كلام
باطل ولم يقل به ائمه ائمه الاسلام بل
اجمع الصحابه والتابعون وعلماء وائمه
المسلمين قديما وحديثا على ان الله سبحانه
وتعالى الاصل في كتابه
الحقيقه
وكذلك اجمعوا على ان الله سبحانه وتعالى
استوى على عرشه فوق خلقه استواء يليق
بجلاله يليق بجلاله لا نقول كيف جاء احد
الناس في زمن مالك بن انس
الامام رحمه
الله
فساله الرحمن على العرش استوى كيف
استوى
قال الاستواء معلوم يعني في
اللغه والكيف غير معقول
او مجهول في روايه هيك وروايه هيك غير
معقول يعني لا يمكننا ان نعقل هذا
الشيء والايمان به واجب والسؤال عنه
بدعه وهلم جر في جميع صفات الله سبحانه
وتعالى هذا هو
الميزان اذا جاءتنا صفه من صفات الله او
فعل من افعاله
نقول هذا الشيء معلوم في اللغه والكيف غير
معقول لا يمكن للانسان ان يحيط بالله
سبحانه وتعالى علما ولا
فهما من هذه الناحيه والايمان به واجب
لانه في القران وفي السنه والسؤال عنه
بدعه لان الصحابه رضي الله عنهم وهم احرص
على العلم لم يسالوا في
هذا ولم يسالوا لانهم علموا ان ثم حد
وصلوا حد ادنى حد او اقصى حد وصلوا اقصى
حد
للعقل
ف لا سؤال عن
الكيفيه الله سبحانه وتعالى خاطبنا بما
نفهم واما الكيفيه فهي الى الله سبحانه
وتعالى ولا يحيطون به علما الله سبحه
وتى
الله p that you can see so in
this very for us
understand
exactly prop صل الله عليه
وس
‏manys time compiling all of the belief
and the
tradition of the arabs during the time
of صل الله عليه وسلم
that
for for of
the debates for many of the evidences
‏are
resp these things are adding a state of
being that the arabs in so for us to get
the whole picture we need to understand
exactly what their state of belief was
the arabs in the time of الله عليه
وسلم
‏ide الله سبحانه
وران time صل الله عليه وسل all belied
exence of creat and all
believed i say allan all tribes all
ma and they
alled
‏that the originator the creat of all
the
creation is one
more look
could underst that
they mple
cre
‏could that or
could the raises the heavens rais the
heavens
without any pills visible pillars or
without any
pillars it
could ‏happened on its own or happen
stance or the big bang or any of these
other things however that cannot be the
case either because the arabs at the
time of the propet صل عليه ولم did not
have any qus with this they belied in
this and they agreed to
this they conceded to fact that الله is
the only creator سبحانه وتالى in order
for us understand the verse properly we
have to understand what the verse is
speaking about exactly
‏it
could الله theis the heav nature do it
الله notation of exence of الله why the
ar the prophet صل الله عليه وسلم
sent they did not disb in the
creator nor did they disb in his oneness
the creator oneness what did they
believe
‏yes is one
creat yes he is the originator of all
things
however that one
creator we do not directly approach
him and so he has saints who are free of
sin and we are to
sinful
worship
[Silence]
الله سبحانه
وتالى
‏all
قران
الله
الله صلى الله عليه
وسلم صلى الله عليه
وسلم
‏disb in exence of allah that was ais
ais was not a native belief to the arab
peninsula that was not know no was known
to have disb in the ex of a may few
people
here was
‏ide created came together from cha came
complete harmony
et
these did not not ar time الله عليه
وسلم
‏disb that's how for and alien
these to thein that
time and so we look at the some people
interpret قران based our time to what
does it
me
in well الله the
me not nature
[Silence]
‏none صل
الله
الله عليه
وسلم no intermed no
bu سبحانه
وتعالى
الله اله الله
‏n
الله ان شاء الله والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه
اجمعين